Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P, here is a caller who uses very
disgusting language, some of which we've had to
clean up for our broadcast version of the show.
But he also is making a point that is
just wrong that I disagree with. Let's
just lost my microphone. Oh, my goodness. Did
you guys see that? That was crazy. I literally
just lost my microphone. Let's see if I can get
it plugged back in. Okay. I don't think that's
ever happened on the show before. Okay. That
will probably be Mehmed where the microphone
is back. Let's listen to the voicemail.
Speaker 5: And I just wanted to know why
you prefer to call Joe Biden's not.
Speaker 1: That's a technical term,
the gargling of nuts.
Speaker 5: On a regular basis.
I prefer the Young Turks because they're
less willing to admit that he is a failure
of a president. Right. The a
joke. He does nothing. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I've not seen that episode of Twitter.
Speaker 5: You. You sit back and read the
headlines. The major titles look good in
your own eyes. No, no, no. Sucker cut.
The entire segment. That's what you did. Mm hmm.
So are you funded by the Democratic Party in
any capacity, or are you just that much shill?
For the Democratic Party. I don't understand.
I thought you were smart in this way. Oh. Now
start to doubt my initial assessment of your own.
Come on.
Speaker 1: Man. Come on, man. All right.
So let's go through it point by point. Joe Biden
is basically 20 months into his presidency. For
the first 17 of those 20 months when Joe Biden had
an accomplishment, I would tell you that he had
an accomplishment. And my growing sense was this
presidency was not going well. The approval rating
or lack thereof reflected that. There was there
were long periods without any major legislative
accomplishments. There were a number of different
events that took place for Biden that were not
useful to him. And I called out all of it. And
yes, in the last three of his 20 month presidency,
there is new life in Joe Biden's presidency, a
number of important legislative accomplishments,
a number of good economic factors that only relate
a little bit to Joe Biden. Remember, as as as I
always have, when we see something happen in
the economy that doesn't really have anything
to do with the president, I gladly tell you that.
And I mention it still helps the president when
good things happen in the economy. So I think
that like many callers, one of two things may
be going on. One, they see one of my clips in a
vacuum where I praise something Joe Biden did. And
their takeaway is that I am gargling Joe Biden's.
Let's use a more polite term, apple bags. Okay,
that I'm gargling the apple bags, sucking up to
Joe Biden. I guess the phrase would be because
they don't see my other clips and they haven't
been paying attention to the show long. And that's
one possibility. Other possibility is these people
just don't care and they just want to make these
allegations. And the third possibility is that
they meant to call a different show. That often
will happen. I will sometimes get people who call
and they go, David, that thing you said about,
you know, someone I've never even talked about
that was absolutely horrible. I'm unsubscribing.
I don't think you were even subscribed to me
because I don't even know what you're talking
about. So any of these possibilities are on the
table. But I have been very critical of the Biden
administration. The last three months have been
significantly better for him and many indicators
looking better and better economically in the
United States. That's the reality. We have a
fantastic bonus show for you today. It turns out
that the incoming King Charles, the third after
the death of Queen Elizabeth, the second King
Charles will not have to pay inheritance tax on
the queen's private estate, which is worth more
than $750 million. That's a great deal if you can
get it. So we'll talk about what is normally the
inheritance tax in the UK and how it is that King
Charles avoids that. We are going to talk about
Nigeria becoming the first country to ban foreign
models in television ads. Television ads airing in
Nigeria will have to have models, actors, maybe we
would call them who are Nigerian, and we'll talk
about why they're doing it, how you enforce such a
rule and more. And lastly, we are seeing more and
more companies drop vaccine mandates for COVID.
The most interesting thing to me about this
is that for years we were hearing from the
anti-vaccine, right? The vaccine mandates at work
are just the first step in whatever some dystopian
authoritarian slippery slope of tyranny. And we,
the reasonable people, knew all along that's not
going to happen. That's not at all what this is.
This is just vaccine mandates for when it makes
sense, and then it's all going to kind of fade
away. And that's exactly what's happening. And
those people are completely silent at this point
in time. All of those stories and more we will
talk about on today's bonus show when I'm joined
by producer Pat Forde. You can sign up at join
Packman dot com. Couple other things to tell you
about. We will be doing a huge membership special
on 919. That's next Monday, Monday, September
19th. It will be 919 themed. If you would like to
take advantage of this great membership special,
all you need to do is get on my mailing list at
David Pakman dot com. And then on the morning of
919, you will get an email telling you exactly how
to sign up for a discounted membership. All right.
Don't miss it. It's a doozy. My accountant is
saying, David, don't do it. My business manager is
saying, David, know, our lawyer is saying, is this
discount even legal? It's so huge. And I am saying
we're doing it. We are doing it for the people.
And so I look forward to seeing you on the bonus
show either today or after you get that discount.